[applause]
well
i guess i'll be explained that the text was
another one of bugs and recession.
The Austrian pulls out the night with a
new one, he not only
quickly
betrays yours.
[applause] [applause] before hitting the floor and letting go live at the site dude is tough I'm guys [applause] here's coke takes terratec from apple apple then this is a victory here and there in fat32 and takes over the walls of the mega-church in short we take and sing in order to sort out the bass of this miracle and dip the web server of that it is something like that joy come out the floor and Rus' take diablo.
thought it about this clattered from the
shore and besten by
chance they certainly fell
[music]
series
[applause] I
'll go .  linde especially games.  kemerovo
diffusion and i'll black spoons and
pichugin bachek here's a
bunch of this for how long i haven't attacked one
guitar